Errors were made in the hours
following King Viserys' death.
The war will be fought
many will die
and the victim eventually is on the throne.
It's a war between King
There is no war so hateful to the gods.
and no more so bloody as a war between dragons.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie, Happy House of the Dragon Day
They dropped a brand new House of
the Dragon Season 2 trailer.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs here, a bunch of chaos.
It's not the entire season,
but it is a lot of the season.
Most of the big battle footage.
Seems like it's only up to like the halfway point
through the season.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
of course I'll be doing episode videos for everything,
just like I did for season one for the main show.
so. Be sure to subscribe to get everything
But obviously the important stuff first
it says they're dropping the season
during summer next year 2024.
That probably means somewhere in June or July,
just starting at the beginning of the trailer footage,
working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs wtf moments
and there are many many WTF moments.
Some of them are a little bit easier
to identify than others.
They start with auto high towers.
VOICEOVER Talking about the errors quote
unquote in the hours following King versus his death
with Rhaenyra on Dragonstone looking out over the bay.
she's looking out over storms and in house
but at the end like the actual keep
because she's thinking about her son's death
at the hands of Aemond and Vhagar R.I.P.
Lucerys that's why she looks so haggard
because this seems like it's happening
right after the moments of the ending of season
one Episode ten.
I think they did say
that season two would begin moments after that.
in Auto Hightower's voiceover is obviously just talking
about what they did during the events of episode nine
when right after King versus
is that they moved to lock all the blacks
that were there in their rooms so that they couldn't
do anything while they crowned Aegon the second.
It sounds like he's inside a hall talking to someone.
Maybe he's talking to the blacks.
Maybe he's talking to Rhaenyra.
Why else would he be apologizing to someone in a hall
that way about them taking the iron throne from out
under her feet Then we actually see Aegon ascending
to the Iron throne wearing Aegon the conkers crown.
I think the men walking behind him in the green
robes are just part of the Hightower's regular army.
the people right behind him would be his Kings Guard.
They've obviously changed the King's guard a little bit
since he took the iron throne.
Basically all meant to be people
that support him, support the Greens and remember
all the other lords and ladies,
all the other parts of court here
that are bowing to him as he takes
the iron throne, are people that they forced
to swear fealty to the Greens,
otherwise they would have killed them.
then we see Daemon put on his trademark dragon
armor heading into battle because of all the greenery.
This could be in the riverlands
it could be adherent hall, It could be somewhere else.
It doesn't look like dragons.
So just because there's too much greenery
outside the windows,
then we get the voiceover from Alicent
talking to her father, Otto Hightower, saying
the war will be fought with a picture of the blacks
army preparing for battle here with all their tents.
we see the green army.
I'm not sure where they are in this moment exactly.
This might be them marching on dusk and Dale.
This might be before the sack of dusk.
And Dale, things don't seem super crazy yet like it
seems pretty chill because of the muddy terrain here.
I think this is dusk and dale
that they're about to sack.
this beach here might be on Dragonstone.
This might be them assembling the dragon seeds.
this is probably Kristin called beheading Lord
Dusk and Dale after the successful sack of dusk.
And Dale, he was a supporter of Rhaenyra and the blacks.
in also zooming in.
He has noticed that he's wearing the chain
of the hand of the king, meaning that he's replaced
Otto Hightower as aegon's hand of the king,
a lot of the big battles that will happen
during season two actually come after he's
replaced Otto Hightower as hand of the king.
one of the reasons for
that is because Aegon actually grew impatient thinking
that Otto Hightower was making the wrong call,
trying to bargain with Raniere
and find a less bloody resolution to their civil war.
if you can believe it, Otto Hightower, of all people
who was in favor of them
usurping the Iron Throne from Rhaenyra actually,
initially,
the beginning of the season wanted to find a less
bloody resolution to this problem.
Kristen, Cole and Aegon, however, had a much,
much different idea about how to take care of that.
They wanted all out war.
that's why Kristen Cole just seems so out for blood
during all the parts of this trailer.
so Aegon basically fires Otto Hightower replaces him
with Kristen Clarke
who advocates for the sack of Duncan Dale.
Then the battle at Rooks Rose, which is where
all the big battle scenes come from during this trailer
we see Aegon sitting on the Iron Throne with Aegon,
the Conqueror's crown
and then Rhaenyra with her father versus crown.
this looks like potentially one of the dragons sees
the white dragon would be see smoke
this might be happening on Drift Mark,
which is where sea smoke
has been resting since Lena Valerian disappeared.
Most people thought that he died.
That was part of the whole ruse.
but one of the big things during season two
is that they're searching for the dragon seeds
so that they can actually activate
their unused dragons,
that all the blacks that Daemon really are a control
see smoke being one of them.
this looks like the green army at the battle of Rooks
rest about to begin the battle.
the actual battle is meant to take place around episode
four like the middle of the season.
Basically it'll be like their big WTF moment
that cut the season in half.
Then we get the voiceover from Princess
Rhaenys, who's talking to Rhaenyra, talking
about the dance of the Dragons. Basically,
there's no war.
This is hateful to the gods
as one within the family, essentially.
while they're in the map table room at Dragonstone,
looking out over their battle plans.
we briefly see Corlys Velaryon.
He only appears once in the trailer here,
as far as I know.
not totally sure who Daemon is attacking here,
who is hacking away at there, we get the shot of Aemond
in the dark in the Iron Throne room, staring
at the empty iron throne, the whole thing about that.
But normally you would think, wait, does he trying
to usurp the iron throne from his brother Aegon
the only thing about that is
you have to remember that Aemond.
Even though it seems like he covets his sister Helaena.
actually has
this very Ned Stark, like, adherence to duty and honor.
So even if he thinks that he would be better on
the Iron Throne, he's not going to try and usurp
his brother.
He's still going to support the natural order,
as the Greens see it,
which would be Aegon being the rightful heir
as the way that they see it.
maybe we'll see some conflict within him
during the events of season two, Season three.
Like the whole idea is that he feel like
he'd be a better king than Aegon,
but he's not going to try
and take the iron throne from his brother
Remember though, during the events of season one
when Aegon was like, I don't want it.
Like he pulled a Jon Snow on almond
when Amy was trying to drag him
kicking and screaming to his coronation,
he basically told Aemond, You take it,
you take the iron throne Notice
they've placed the green banners behind it to
this is meant to be the Green's banner
for House Targaryen with the gold sigil on it. day.
We get our first shot of the North
in a long, long time.
So this is probably on their way
to house stark it could be on their way to the wall.
This might be the stark men,
it could be the night's watch.
We will see how stark we will see Winterfell.
We'll see Cregan Stark.
there's, like a whole bloody civil war
that how Stark fought internally with itself
during the big time jump during the events of season
one that we'll get into during
season two at some point
there's like a whole other video that I could do.
I actually did a video on Cregan start talking
a little bit about that, so I'll post links for it
in the description below, But essentially, Cregan
and House Stark become big supporters of Rhaenyra
because he went through
pretty much the same thing that just happened to rain
or is in the middle of happening to Rhaenyra right now
with someone trying to take her throne from her
another person.
Within House Stark tried to take, how stark from Cregan
Stark, who was the rightful heir.
this looks like Allison
in what might be the Riverlands.
there's a lot of chaos in the riverlands
during season two.
Then we see Rhaenyra with Cyrus on the beach.
Maybe Dragonstone may be drift marked with whoever
seems like they wind up writing sea smoke.
This might be one of the whole brothers
they cast Adam Hall from the books and Allen Hall
who are going to be dragons these during season two
And neither one of them will be like a secret version
of Eleanor who's coming back
pretending to be one of the whole brothers,
this is just a wide shot from the outside of King's
landing, showing you the dragon pit with the red key,
obviously the Dragon Pit in center of frame
because of all the dragons
a big part of Rainey's warning to
Rhaenyra is about this civil war between the family
with the Dragons
like nothing is going to be as bad as this giant war
we're going to fight in all the dragons of the chaos
is going to cause.
this is actually Helaena in her morning gown.
That's where she's got the fabric over her face.
I don't want to get too deep into this
because this is after the events of blood and cheese.
If you've read the books,
you know what blood and cheese are.
You know how crazy it's going to be.
There are a couple blood and cheese moments
here later in the trailer
that's basically going to be episode one.
Like they will start the season with blood and cheese
when they dropped the official posters
for season two,
basically said blood for blood, Blood for blood.
An eye for an eye. A son for a son.
this is the procession with the cart with their bodies
being led through the streets of King's Landing,
while they're all in mourning,
all these shots of them fighting in the woods,
running through the woods on horseback.
Seem like they're from the battle at Rooks Rest,
I think the person on horseback here might be Kristen
called the fire burning.
The Green's siege weapon here would belong to Princess
Rhaenys and her dragon Meraxes.
These who was the only dragon belonging to the blacks
fighting at Rooks
against Aegon, who was on Sun Fire in Aemond on Vhagar
are who we see later in the trailer.
So it's like two dragons against one
during this battle.
but part of the idea is that Princess
Rhaenys was way, way more experienced on Dragon back
way better fighter than both Aemond and Aegon.
Then Princess Rhaenys is reminding Rhaenyra
no war is bloody as a war between dragons,
meaning that we're going to see actual dragons
fighting during season two.
A lot of people been waiting for that,
like one of the promises of House of the Dragon,
a bunch of dragons fighting each other in the air.
It's going to be crazy.
not exactly sure what's going on here,
but this is Princess Baela on her dragon moondancer
screaming also not totally sure
what the chaos in King's Landing is going on here.
This might be either the sack of King's Landing
or they might think the king's landing
is in danger of being sacked.
And that's why Alicent is running around in chaos.
the actual sack of King's landing seems more like
a season three kind of moment for House of the Dragon.
Daemon seems like he's inside a cave.
So this might be inside the dragon Mont on Dragonstone.
Then some of you probably guessed this is blood
and cheese in episode one, grabbing Helaena Targaryen.
Like I said, if you know you know, please don't post
spoilers for Blood and Cheese in the comments below.
it is going to be crazy.
this is more of kristen call of the battle a rooks rest
this looks like the battle of the Cargill brothers.
They might be at King's Landing here.
Not exactly sure which room they're in
when this is happening.
part of the idea is that the Cargyll twins
are on opposite sides of the dance of the Dragons.
They wind up battling each other.
it leans very heavily into the metaphor of family
against family
with the targaryens,
the greens and the blacks going at each other.
there are a couple of shots almond on Vhagar
then immediately to Rhaenyra on Syrax.
But here's the thing
that's not actually happening in the same moment.
Like they're not fighting each other on Dragon back
because at least in the books, Rhaenyra
never actually fights any of the other dragons
when she's on Syrax.
Maybe they've changed that for the TV show
a little bit.
It would be a big change in the books, but in the books
it was one of the big reasons why some of the small
folk did not support Rhaenyra
because she didn't actually do any fighting on Syrax.
a lot of people felt like she was forcing
everyone else to fight her battles for her.
She didn't actually fight in any of the battles
herself.
Aemond,
however, fought a ton, a ton of battles on Vhagar
He loved that which we see with him
on Vhagar at the battle at Rooks Rest.
then we get the logo in a bunch of fire.
So obviously there's a ton of crazy stuff
going on in the trailer here.
But like I said, it seems like most of this
footage is from like the first half of the season,
maybe like a little bit
from the second half of the season, but mostly
the first half is just meant to be the teaser trailer.
if there's any Easter Eggs
or references that you spotted in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video, just write them
below in the comments or any big questions
you have about stuff that happens in the trailer.
I will do more bonus videos as we get more footage
and learn more about the actual season
because it's Brazil. Comic-Con sees the XP.
There are a bunch of other trailer videos
that are dropping this weekend,
so I'll do videos for them as fast as possible.
Like the boys Season four.
click Here for all my other House of The Dragon Season
2 previews in Teasers and click here
for that Game of Thrones night of the Seven Kingdoms
teaser trailer that they dropped.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!